SCP-682 VS SCP-3042.
Could the ultimate case of Puppy Love be the
force to counteract SCP-682’s reptilian
hatred?
Let’s take a look and see.
SCP-3042 is a small but superpowered dog that
bonds with one individual at a time, and basically
gradually loves them to death with constant
and unyielding affection.
Its latest favorite person was eaten by SCP-682,
causing SCP-3042 to imprint on the monster
as a replacement.
However, this was disastrous,
as SCP-682 immediately
attacked the tiny dog, causing it to run away
in fear.
SCP-3042 charged through
a nearby wall - thankfully
making a hole too small for SCP-682 to escape
through - and imprinted on a nearby guard.
Another test failed.